also was wir jetzt aus
sicherheitskreisen auch bestätigt
bekommen haben bei den mutmaßlichen
täter der tot in seiner wohnung
aufgefunden wurde handelt es sich um
einen mann namens tobias r
er war bisher nicht vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet oder dort
bekannt so zumindest der stand jetzt man
hat dort aber wohl auch ein
bekennerschreiben gefunden und ein video
das deutlich darauf schließen lässt dass
der mann aus rechtsextremistischen
motiven ausländerfeindlichen motiven
gehandelt hat dafür spricht auch dass
der generalbundesanwalt jetzt die
ermittlungen an sich gezogen hat denn er
streitet ja nur ein und übernimmt den
fall nur dann wenn das sich um fälle von
besonderer bedeutung handelt was im
moment aber noch nicht klar ist oder
nicht ganz abzusehen ist die motivlage
es gibt dieses bekennerschreiben das
wird im moment aber noch ausgewertet
zumindest deutet aber vieles darauf hin
dass er eben aus rechtsextremistischen
motiven gehandelt hat die spekulationen
die gestern abend frühzeitig auf kamen
zum beispiel bandenkriege oder
islamistische motive oder amoklauf
scheint damit erstmal vom tisch zu sein
die ersten schüsse fallen gegen 22 uhr
danach geht der angreifer in eine shisha
bar am heumarkt im zentrum von hanau
augenzeugen berichten von acht bis neun
schüssen vier menschen sterben hier
danach fährt er eine weitere shisha bar
im stadtteil kesselstadt dort tötet der
mann fünf menschen in den frühen
morgenstunden findet die polizei die
leiche des mutmaßlichen täters in dessen
wohnung in der helmholtzstraße daneben
ein weiteres opfer insgesamt sprechen
wir derzeit von elf getöteten personen
das sind also jetzt die beiden an dem
neuen tatort in der helmholtzstraße
dazugerechnet über die anzahl der
verletzten können wir im moment noch
nichts sagen sind aber mehrere verletzte
die polizei geht nicht davon aus dass es
einen weiteren täter gibt
[Applaus]